dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale il ya la guerre en
ukraine et ce nouveau bombardement à qui
a visé l'aéroport denis procès dans le
centre est du pays selon le gouverneur
de la région l'aéroport lui-même les
infrastructures à proximité ont été
totalement détruits impossible pour
l'heure de déterminer le nombre de
victimes on va tout de même retrouvés du
côté duman karim rihawi bonjour vous
êtes notre envoyé spécial pour un peu
comprendre là où vous trouvez ou mal
c'est un passage de privilégier lorsque
l'on veut quitter l'est de l'ukraine on
attend donc là où vous vous trouvez dans
les prochaines heures une arrivée
certainement massue de déplacés en
provenance de dnipro
alors il va sûrement y avoir des gens
qui vont passer par oman s'est quasiment
inévitable d'ailleurs quand on est
arrivés par ici en provenance de l'ouest
du pays on a croisé beaucoup de voitures
avec des plaques d'immatriculation en
provenance de deux nièces ou de karkhiv
c'est vrai que on a beaucoup parlé de
ses convois humanitaires depuis hier
mais ce samedi un peu moins de 5000
personnes ont réussi à être évacués donc
on voit bien qu'un certain nombre de
citoyens de l'est du pays tentent de
partir par leurs propres moyens vous le
disiez tout à l'heure dans la nuit eh
bien il va y avoir un certain nombre de
cars qui vont quitter notamment dnipro
qui est en quelque sorte le premier
point de passage lorsqu'on quitte les
zones les zones du dombass un car qui va
de t'avoir arrivé ici du côté d'où la
dont s'est entretenu avec un responsable
responsable du domaine agricole parce
que ici cette région est une région
extrêmement agricole c'est un peu le
centre du blé ukrainien et dc beaucoup
des départs en direction du donbass
notamment de la nourriture mais aussi
des chauffeurs pour aller chercher des
gens mais ils vont beaucoup de
difficultés à aller ramener mais en tout
cas
on espère ici du côté de man que ça va
se fluidifier un peu alors vous avez
évoqué la situation adli pro qui est la
grande ville aux abords du dombass qui a
été bombardé qui est bombardé déjà
depuis un moment déjà cet aéroport qui a
été frappée aujourd'hui il avait déjà
été par le passé aidé ni pro est en
quelque sorte la plaque tournante un peu
la plaque névralgique pour évacuer
l'ensemble de ceux qui tentent de
quitter karkhiv severodonezk ou encore
les régions qui sont palois de louhansk
et de diest c'est à dire ceux dont basse
ou les russes ont renforcé leur
dispositif en abandonnant peu à peu
notamment la région de kiev 1 karim
rihaoui envoyé spécial de france 24 en
ukraine merci à vous karim pour toutes
ces informations